THE COMPANY. CARE ALL RIGHT.
BERMAN. GOOD AFTERNOON AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO CALL THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BANKING
AND FINANCE TO ORDER. DUE TO
THE CONTINUED STAY AT HOME
ORDER WE PART WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEN HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHING FIRST
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT NASTY WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT. THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITES. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
YOU WITH ONE. WE DO HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM TODAY IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE MINIMAL CONTINGENT
OF STAFF AND LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL. I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE MY
PHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING. OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE THE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SEEN. UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL THE CALLING NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
THREE TWO SIX TWO. FOUR TWO.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THE NUMBER N
THE ASSEMBLY BANKING COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS YOUR TV OR
MONITOR SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU THE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN. PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING. YOUR LIVE LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESSES PROVIDING TESTIMONY
FOR OR AGAINST A BILL YOU WERE
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE. AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE THREE
ZERO EIGHT ONE AND THE STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP
YOU. I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION.
OF THE LETTER PORTER ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS AS WELL.
FOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL ASK A
QUESTION OR PROVIDE A COMMENT.
YOU WILL NEED TO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE TO STAFF AN
ACTIVATED WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO
PLEASE STAND UP AND FACE THE
MICROPHONE WHILE SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND CAN BE RECORDED. I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE AND THINK THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE SUBSTITUTING A
COMMITTEE TODAY. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO CONGRATULATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUFFY WICKS ON THE BIRTH OF HER
DAUGHTER ELLIE. WE SEND YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY ARE WARM WISHES.
FIRST OF CITY WE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
THREE OF US AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARC BERMAN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU ALL
SUBSTITUTES. FOR JOINING US
TODAY. SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
TODAY WE HAVE A TOTAL OF TWO
BILLS ONE ON CONSENT AND- ONE
AND THAT WE WILL BE HEARING. DO
I HAVE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION BY GRAYSON AND A SECOND
BY. BEFORE ANY FEDERAL
TECHNICALITY SO WE WILL START
WITH CALLING THE ROLE. MON HERE
THE MOUNTAINEER TEN. CAN HEAR
BARRICADED MAN A. N. HERE
BERMAN BERMAN HERE BURKE BURKE
HERE BONG BONG HERE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HERE GRAYSON RIGHT IN
HERE THREE OF US THREE OF US
HERE DOWN. DOWN HERE VOEPEL
VOEPEL HERE WEBER WEBER HERE.
ALRIGHT NOW THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION- BY SOME MEMBER
GRAYSON IN A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG FOR AT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CAN WE PLEASE
TAKE ROLE IN THAT. SB FIVE
FIFTY TWO THE MOTION TO DO
PASSED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. AMOUNT HI RAMON
HI SAN. GEN HI BARRICADE IN A.
R. K. HI. BERMAN HI BURKE BURKE
FONG. BONTA NIGHT GAVE. GABRIEL
HI GRAYSON GRAYSON MOVED.
THREE OF US I DON'T. STONE
VOEPEL VOEPEL HI WEBER WEBER.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES THANK
YOU CONSENT WITH SB TWO TWO HAS
A UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND THE IS
DEEP TO PER AND THAT PASSES.
NOW WE WILL HEAR FROM SENATOR
MCCASKEY WHO WERE PRESENTED SB
NINE OH EIGHT. MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES- SERVICE TO
COLLEAGUES FIRST OFF I'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR
THE STAFF AND FOR THE SHEER AND
AT THE WORK DEBATE- DID THAT
DONE ON THIS BILL AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE CONTAINED AND- URINALYSIS.
SB NINE AWAIT SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA USED TO DO AND WE
SHOULD HAVE REINSTATED A LONG
TIME AGO IS THAT WE LICENSE THE
COLLECTION OF DEBT AND THE DEBT
BUYING INDUSTRY. WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD CONSUMER
LAWS ON THE BOOKS REQUIRING
FAIR DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES
THESE LAWS DO LITTLE TO
PROHIBIT. A BAD BEHAVIOR- WHICH
THEY'RE INTENDED TO CHEER. THIS
IS BECAUSE CURRENTLY THE LAW
REQUIRES THAT EACH INDIVIDUAL
BETTER PASSED THE INDIVIDUALLY
SUE THE COMPANY IF THEY THINK
THAT THEY'RE- RIGHT TO BE IN
VIOLATION. HAVE BEEN VIOLATED
AND THAT IS TO SIMPLY DOESN'T
WORK AS A STAFF. ANALYSIS POINT.
MADAM AND MEMBERS HERE TO
REPORT THAT I HAVE. THAT
COLLECTION AND DEBT BUYING
INDUSTRY. AND I CAN SAY TO YOU
THAT WHILE STILL MAINTAINING
MANY CONSUMER PROTECTIONS SB
NINE AWAIT NOW HAS THE SUPPORT
OF THESE TWO INDUSTRIES THAT
WERE LICENSING. SB NINE AWAIT
BLOOD CALIFORNIA TO LIST OF
THIRTY FOUR OTHER STATES THAT
REQUIRE A LICENSE IN ORDER TO
COLLECT ON CONSUMER DEBT. WITH
ME AND SUPPORT I HAVE MAR
ISABELLE TOURIST WHO'S WITH HE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
AND TED BERMAN WITH A CLICK THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION AND I WOULD URGE AN
IBOOK. THANK YOU CENTER AT
CASCADE NEVER AGAIN TO HEAR
FROM SUPPORT WITNESSES AND I
REMIND AS WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THAT THEY HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH. OUR FIRST WITNESS IN
SUPPORT WILL BE TESTIFYING OVER
THE PHONE. MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH. MONEY SIBEL
TAURUS WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING
ON SENATE BILL NINE OH EIGHT.
THOROUGHFARE LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GERMANY MONNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING THEIR
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH EIGHT TO
REQUIRED DEBT COLLECTORS TO BE
LICENSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT THE CENTER
FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING WORKS
TO ENSURE A FAIR INCLUSIVE
MARKETPLACE FOR CONSUMERS AND
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE
NIGHT OF A WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS CHEAPER. WE
OFFERED TO THE BILL DOES NOT
ACCEPT ATTORNEYS WHO REGULARLY
ENGAGE IN THE PRACTICE OF THAT
COLLECTION MANY THAT COULD
CONFIRM THANKFULLY WEAPONIZED
THE COURT SYSTEMS TO HARASS
COULD DIVERT AND OPERATE A
BLOCK TO MILK FINALLY THOUSAND
COLLECTION MARKETS A YEAR AND
OFTEN WITHOUT PROPER REVIEW OF
A REGIONAL ACCOUNT
DOCUMENTATION. SB NINETY WAIT
HAS BEEN LONG NEEDED TO
REGULATE THIS INDUSTRY BEFORE
THE ONSET OF THE COOKING
NINETEEN PANDEMIC US HELPFUL
THAT WAS ON THE RISE REACHING
OVER FOURTEEN TRILLION DOLLARS
WITH THE GROWING AMOUNT
SPENDING FROM NON MORTGAGE.
CONSUMER DEBT. PEOPLE LOSE JOBS
HAVE HOURS. IN OTHER WORDS
PEOPLE TO HARM ECONOMIC EFFECTS
OF THE TEN THEN I. WE EXPECT A
FEW OF IN THE WITH THESE
DEFAULT. THE DEBT. PEOPLE WILL
BE EXPOSED TO COLLECTOR THE
FIRE. I INCREASED THREE. FOR
HER TO GET THE END. FALLOUT THE
PANDEMIC WILL BE THE SAME
EXPOSE THE DEBT COLLECTION IN
MEDIA. AND THE LONG TERM. WE
NEED THE UNITED EIGHT TO PUT
THAT I. WHO USE THE- RECESSION.
OF OPPORTUNITY TO UPON
DESPERATE THE WOMAN. THE OVER.
FORTY AUTHORITY LONGER. ACCOUNT
HAS HAD LOTS OF PLACE YOUR CALL
FORGET COLLECTION. SINCE THEN I
SEVENTIES THEY DO LITTLE STEM
THE- BEHAVIOR THAT THERE'S A-
TO COME. WITHOUT MY- AND RIGHT.
THAT COLLECT LARGELY OFF. ON IN.
REGULATOR HAVE NO. HOW OFFER
WITHIN OUR- OR WHAT. BECAUSE
ARE. EMPLOYEES IN THAT SOUTH OF
THE CAL. IN THE LIFE COULD BE.
AWAY FROM THE COLOR. ACTING IN
BAD. SB NINE AWAIT WILL ACT
HELLO TO THE THIRTY FOUR OTHER
REQUIRE LIKE THE TO COLLECT
CONSUMER DATA. YOU BADLY NEED
OVERSIGHT THE BILL PROVIDE ANY
RESPECTFULLY AFTER SUPPORT WITH
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR SECOND WITNESS IN SUPPORT
IS TEN. WHO WILL BE. OVER THE
NOT MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE.
US TEMER. OUR MENU LINE OF OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR NAY. CLICK IS
THAT STATE WIDE ALLIANCE OF AID
PROVIDERS EVERY DAY THEM FOR
REGULAR THAT COLLECTORS CAL.
FIRST OF. FIRST AND POOR OF THE
PROVIDE BY A NINE AWAY ARE
STILL GOOD RIGHT NOW. QUICKLY
GO SERVICE PROVIDER THE DAY AND
DEBT COLLECTOR. LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE THE ONE GROUP MATH
MAILED THOUSANDS OF IMMIGRANTS
INCLUDING A CALL I WOULD MISTER.
CORRECTING COULD BE HOME FOR
WAY. FOR DEBT THAT NEVER EXISTS.
AT THE END IT MAKES THE NEED
FOR THE BILL EVEN MORE. I DON'T
STORES AND PAYMENT BOB FAMILY
WILL BE FORCED TO AGONY
DECISION. WHICH WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY INCLUDE THEMSELVES
WITH THE WE NEED BILL NOW NOT
ONLY TO LIKELY GO TO FOLLOW THE
LAW. BUT ALSO TO DETERMINE BAD
ACT TO A- CD ECONOMIC IS NOT
BETWEEN TO PRAY ON DESPERATE.
THANK SB NINE AWAIT NEEDS TO
INCLUDEAGE LIKE ANYTHING THE
TURN ACT THIRD PARTY COLLECTOR.
AGENCY OVER OF FINANCIAL. I
TURN AND LAW FIRM ARE ON. AMONG
WORST BY UP ABOUT THE ACT. FOR
THEM ONE TWO MILES. FERNANDO
WITH OVERLY FILE FIRM ILLEGAL
PRACTICAL OUT BANK. THAT SHE
AGREED TO MAKE ON A- THAT SHE
DID. AND QUIET MCGRAW. THE
CORRECT BY LAW FIRM DECAL TO
TRY THE FOR THE SALE HIS FATHER
HOME MISTER GUY DIDN'T AGREE TO
PAY. EVEN I WOULDN'T INCOME OF
EXEMPT FROM COLLECTION AND THE
THREAT ON ALL. MEMBERS YOU KNOW
WELL THE BANKS AND ALL
FINANCIAL BENEFIT FROM GUARD
REYES TO KEEP THEM FROM HEY
OPENING A ACCOUNTS FOR WHEN NO
ONE IS THAT HIM TO. FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE ON FOR NOT IN
THE FROM FACT THE DAY COLLECTED
EITHER. FOR EXAMPLE ONE BANKS
TYPICALLY CALL CLAYTON WANTED
TO. AND THEN NICK CLAYTON FOR
THE THING THAT LIKELY LATER AND
WOULDN'T DROP OFF. ANOTHER DDL
AND FINANCIAL AT THE HAS BEEN
THE SINGLE LARGEST. OF THE
SMALL COURT FOR THIS. DURING
THE- HAVING FILED THOUSAND
LAWSUITS AGAINST HE- WHO ARE
OFTEN AT HIGHER RISK FOR THE
VIRUS AND AFRAID TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMES. SB NINE OH EIGHT WILL A
LOT PLAYING FIELD FOR THAT. AND
PROVIDE MUCH SHE RELIEF THAT.
COMPETE CLICK IT TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND DRIVE. AND THANK YOU.
MODERATOR WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE AWAIT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO THE
BOARD AT THE NINE OH EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE THAN THEIR
OWN NOW. AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AT THE NINE OH EIGHT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
AND WE DO HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN
THE QUEUE FOR PERSONAL TIMELINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
RICHARD REPAIRING THE DIRECTOR
OF LITIGATION AND COBAN OR WHAT
THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE AWAIT THANK YOU. WELL
NEXT COURT TO LINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ANTONIO PAREJO WITH CONSUMER
REPORTS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE AWAIT WHICH
WOULD CLOSE LONGSTANDING
CONSUMER PROTECTION GAP IN
STATE LAW BY REQUIRING DEBT
COLLECTORS DO YOU LIKE TO DO
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES
CALIFORNIA HAS LAGGED BEHIND
MOST OTHER STATES BY AROUND
DEBT COLLECTORS TO OPERATE
WITHOUT Y. T. D. OR
SUPERVISION. DVO ALL TO RECEIVE
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS ABOUT DEBT
COLLECTORS HOWEVER BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
SUPERVISORY JURISDICTION OVER
DEBT COLLECTORS THAT LACKS THE
LEGAL TOOL TO INVESTIGATE
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS THIS LACK
OF THE FORTY SPECIALLY
TROUBLING NOW AT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHICH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LIKELY TO
BEAR THE BURDEN TO BOTH
COMPANIES SHE- AND THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC CRISIS. COULD BE
ESPECIALLY HARD TO PROGRESS THE
DEBT COLLECTION ACTIVITY GOES
UNCHECKED IN THE COMING MONTHS.
IN LIGHT OF THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC CRISIS COMMUNITIES ARE
THINKING OF CROSS THE STATE IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY THREE T.
FINANCIAL SHOCKS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO FURTHER. FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
MEASURE AND REQUEST. I THANK
YOU. NEXT ON. LINE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWENTY
NEARLY IS BUILT YOU MAY BE
NEEDED. MAPFUMO TO LINE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROBERT
HER WELL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND WE THANK BOTH THE
CHAIRMAN AND THE AUTHOR FOR
THEIR HARD WORK TO PROTECT
PEOPLE MOST VULNERABLE. THANK
YOU. AND AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AT THE NINE OH EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW
AGAIN SUPPORT FOR AT E. NINE L.
AID TO LONDON ZERO NOW WILL NOT
MOVE TO LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DAVID REBOUND WITH.
A SUBSTANTIAL INTERNATIONAL
FINALLY I REPRESENTS BANKS
CREDIT UNIONS THAT BUYING
COMPANIES AND COLLECTION
AGENCIES WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF PASSAGE OF THAT SET
UP THEIR OWN ANACHRONISM LAW.
AND I PERSONALLY WANT TO EXPAND
THAT- OUR APPRECIATION TO
CENTER WHITE HOUSE BEFORE-
WORKING- WITH THE ARMY I HELP
FROM ABOUT. AND THANK YOU. AT
THE REMAIN FOR THE POOR FOR AT
EMAIL L. EIGHT PRESS ONE THERE
ARE NOW AGAIN THE POOR FOR AT
B. NOW L. EIGHT ONE AT THE END
THERE NOW. WE DO NOT SHOW
ANYONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME GREAT THANK YOU WE'VE BEEN
INFORMED THAT WE HAVE NO ONE TO
REMOTE SITES. IN SUPPORT OF THE
WHICH IS THE SB NINE OH EIGHT.
AND I DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE GO TO THE
MICROPHONE. ON YOUR NOT. IN
SUPPORT NO OKAY SO NO MEMBERS
IN THE HERE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH EIGHT NOW
WE WILL TRANSITION TO BE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I REMIND THE
WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE. TWO
MINUTES EACH. OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WILL BE TESTIFYING
OVER THE PHONE MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CONNECT US. WITH
MICHAEL LOW WHO WILL TESTIFY.
ON SENATE BILL NINE OH EIGHT IN
OPPOSITION. HELLO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS MIKE BELOW IT ON BEHALF
OF THE- CALIFORNIA CREDITORS
BAR ASSOCIATION- I'D LIKE TO
START BY SAYING WE'VE HAD A
VERY VERY RESPECTFUL
DISAGREEMENT WAS CENTER WITH
CASSIDY'S BEEN GENEROUS WITH
HIS TIME- AND HIS STAFF YEAH
COMMITTEE STAFF- I REPRESENT
LAWYERS AND LAW FIRMS TO
REPRESENT CLIENTS IN THE
COLLECTION OF DATA SOMETIMES
IT'S CONSUMER DEBT SUBJECT TO
THIS BILL SOMETIMES IT'S EITHER
DEAD CHILD SUPPORT DEBT
CONTRACT AT. ALL SORTS OF DEATH.
LAST YEAR'S CENTER ACCOUNTS HAD
A WHICH MADE IT COULD CLEAR
THAT LOW AND LAW FIRMS. ARE
SUBJECT TO THE ROSENTHAL FAIR
DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES ACT
AND THAT IS AN APPLE PIE BY THE
STATE BAR ACT. WHICH SAYS IN
SECTION SIX OH SEVEN SEVEN
POINT FIVE. THAT ALL LICENSEES
THAT IS ALL LICENSE LAWYERS
MUST COMPLY WITH THE ROSENTHAL
FAIR DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES
ACT AND IF THEY DON'T THEY'RE
SUBJECT TO DISCIPLINE SO TO PUT
IN ANOTHER WAY. A LAWYER
SUBJECT TO DISBARMENT FOR A
VIOLATION OF THE ROSENTHAL ACT.
SO WE SUGGEST THAT THERE IS NO
GAP IN LICENSING THEY ARE
LICENSED FOR EXACTLY THIS
FUNCTION IT'S NOT AS IF DPO IS
GOING TO HAVE ONE FORM OF
ACTIVITY THERE REGULATING AND
THE STATE BAR ANOTHER. IT'S
CALL PRECISELY THE SAME
FUNCTION- I I'VE HEARD TODAY
THE CONTENTION THAT THESE FIRMS
WHICH HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED AS
MILLS THEY ARE IN FACT LAW
FIRMS REPRESENTING CLIENTS- BUT
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE STATE BAR
DID WERE THERE COMPLAINTS MADE
TO THE STATE BAR DID THEY NOT
ACT- AND AS WAS. ARGUED IN THE
SENATE IF THE ISSUES THAT THE
STATE BAR ISN'T ROBUSTLY
ENFORCING THE LAWS AND THAT'S A
SEPARATE CONVERSATION. BUT WE
SIMPLY DON'T BELIEVE THERE ARE
TO BE TO LICENSES FOR PRECISELY
THE SAME FUNCTION. APPLE THAT
WE CONTINUETO HAVEA
RESPECTFUL DIALOGUE WITH CENTER
WOOD COUNTY BUT WERE. OPPOSED
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL I IF YOU CAN PLEASE CA. US
WITH MELANIE CLEVERNESS. GLAD
THE AIRLINE ITSELF. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT
MELANIE CUEVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
AND AN UNFORTUNATE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AT
THE NINE OH EIGHT I HAVE BURKE
I'D LIKE TO MAKE IT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR THAT WE ARE NOT OPPOSED
TO THE LICENSING AND OVERSIGHT
OF DEBT COLLECTORS WE APPLAUD
THE DESIRE TO PROVIDE
SUPERVISION TO A GROUP OF
ENTITIES THAT CURRENTLY OPERATE
ON LIFE AND- WE EMBRACE
CONSUMER PROTECTION HOWEVER WE
ASK FOR A THOUGHTFUL APPROACH
THAT RECOGNIZES THE EXISTING
REGULATORY PROVISIONS THAT ARE
MEMBER DEPOSITORY INSTITUTIONS.
WHO ARE HEAVILY REGULATED
ALREADY ABIDE BY AND THAT THE
SCOPE OF THE MEASURE BE
NARROWED TO SOLELY FOCUS ON
UNLICENSED ENTITIES WHICH WILL
BE A SUBSTANTIAL UNDERTAKING IN
AND OF ITSELF THANK ARE ALREADY
SUBJECT TO THE PROVISIONS OF
THE ROSENTHAL FAIR DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES ACT AND
ARE SUBJECT TO MULTIPLE IS YOUR
FOR AGENCIES AND REGULAR RATE.
GREAT AND FOR UP WHILE THE
MEASURE OF PROVIDE THEM FROM
FOR THE PA IN. THE MEASURE AND
POWER THROUGH TV WITH
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT AND
AUTHORITY OVER THESE ENTITIES
HOWEVER WE HAVE NOT HEARD OF
LONGSTANDING THE FACT IN THE
CURRENT REGULATORY PROCESS OF
THE ETERNAL ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
ENFORCEMENT OF OR THE BALL THAT
WOULD LEAD TO ADDITIONAL
GRANTED BY A. MEASURE NOW KNOW
SAID THAT AND PRACTICES REMAIN
ATOP. OF THE CFPB. NON THAT.
GENERATE THE OVER RIGHT OF
THOSE COMPLAINTS. FIFTY TV THAT
INDICATE THAT OF THE COMPLETE
AT THIRTY WITH THE OF MAJORITY
THOSE ARE RESPONDED TO CLOSE
AND IT. MANNER I THINK I KNOW A
THE TIME ON EXPANDING LIKE AND
OVER YEAH LIFE AND THAT
COLLECTOR IS A MORE. BONDS AND
ENOUGH LAYER OVER TO. ABSENT
OTHER OF A DIVISION AND ARE
EXISTING REGULAR STRUCK WE-
REQUEST THAT THE ROAD.
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR DEPOSITORY
INSTITUTIONS IS A KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT THE DEBT COLLECTOR
LICENSING ACT BE NARROWED TO
FOCUSING ON JUST THAT. LATENT
THING UNLIKE THE DEBT
COLLECTORS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND THE
FOR. TODAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
DO WE ANY AND- COLORS WOULD
LIKE TO. IN UP. SB NINE AWAIT.
SURE AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSED S. B.
NINE ONLY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW AGAIN IT TO OPPOSE AT B.
NINE NO EIGHT. ONE AND THEN
ZERO NOW. AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE
DO HAVE TO IN THE QUEUE IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. ALL
RIGHT FIRST GLOBAL TO LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GLAD. HI MADAM
CHAIR ROB WILSON WITH A
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
IS ONE OUTLINED MY COMMENTS
WITH- MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE VA
WE ARE CLOSE TO THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. AND THEN MAX
POLITICAL LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CLOSE BURKE- ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT IN BEHALF OF THE DEBT
COLLECTION INDUSTRY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR WITHOUT SKINNER STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY.
COME UP WITH THE BILL THAT BOTH
PROTECTS CONSUMERS IN AS
WORKABLE WITH FROM INDUSTRY
STANDPOINT- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB NINE OH EIGHT ENTER YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS CLASS.
ANY ADDITIONAL WHEN AND AGAIN.
APOLOGIZE TO OPPOSE AT THE
NINOY EIGHT TO ONE THEN THEY'RE
ON NOW AGAIN TO OPPOSE S. B.
NINE OH EIGHT ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
WE DO NOT SHOW ANYONE ELSE AND
LIKE YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
IT'S AND- WE'VE BEEN NOTIFIED
WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE AT THE
REMOTE SITES IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE OH EIGHT WE DO HAVE A-
AT LEAST ONE OR TWO PEOPLE HERE
IN OPPOSITION. TO SB NINE AWAIT
IF YOU CAN DON'T TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE WE CAN. YOU CAN TALK
CAN YOU HEAR ME. GOOD MORNING
WE ARE AYE WEEK THANK YOU. YOU
CAN PRESS THE KAHLER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS WE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR AN
EXEMPTION BUT ONLY TO DRAW A
LINE BETWEEN DEBT COLLECTION
AND INVESTIGATION. THAT IS
REGULATED BY DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS WHEN PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS CONDUCT ANCILLARY
SERVICES TO COLLECT THE DEBT
BUT IT'S NOT ACTUALLY IN THE
PROCESS OF COLLECTING THE DATA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SHARON
MEMBERS JERRY DOES NOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS JUST EMPHASIZING
THAT OUR INVESTIGATIONS THAT
ARE ANCILLARY TO A DEBT
COLLECTION ARE OVERSEEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WITH LICENSE AND ENFORCEMENT
THING FOR ANCILLARY ACTIVITIES
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT NOW
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND OPPOSITION
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE TO BE RECOGNIZED.
DECEMBER TENTH. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- CENTER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY I JUST HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS THE ISSUE OF
CLARIFICATION AS I UNDERSTAND
IT RIGHT NOW. THE STATUS OF A
CURRENT LAW THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS CURRENTLY IN CHARGE
OF THIS OVERSIGHT. AND
ENFORCEMENT óRDENES A WISER
NEED FOR THE DVO ALSO TO BE
EMPOWERED- TO OVERSIGHT THIS
PARTICULAR TYPE OF
INVESTIGATION. THROUGH THE
CHAIR PLEASE SHARE- THE STAFF
REPORT CORRECTLY POINTS OUT
THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL CALMLY
DAVIS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN SUIT-
J. P. MORGAN IN ORDER TO
ENFORCE THEM VIOLATIONS THAT
THEY HAD THE CHALLENGE IS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID IT'S ON
THE INDIVIDUAL DEBTOR IT'S NOT
THAT THE ONE THAT WAS THE ONE
TIME BASED ON ALL THESE
COMPLAINTS THEY GET TO THE
CONSUMERS HAVE A FEDERATION WE
WANT TO HAVE ENFORCEMENT SO
THAT THERE'S A REPORTING AND
THEY CAN TAKE AWAY THAT
LICENSE- IF THEY'RE-
CONDUCTING- OF. BAD BEHAVIOR
THE CHALLENGES BEEN THE WE'RE
NOT CHANGING THE LOG OF THE
LAWSUIT READS THE SAME THE
CHALLENGES BEEN BUT YOU HAVE A
LITTLE BIT BETTER WHOSE- DO YOU
KNOW WHICH KID IS WRONGFULLY
CHARGED FIFTEEN HUNDRED BUCKS
IT DOESN'T MAKE ECONOMIC SENSE
TO DO THAT IN THERE IN THE REAL
pWORLD SO WE WANT TO HAVE THE
AGENCY THAT WILL. IN THE NORMAL
COURSE OF LICENSING WHAT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE IS THAT THAT
THEY HAVE A TEST THEY PAY A FEE
THEY CONDUCT. AND RIGHT TO THE
D. P. O. THAT I'VE I'M BEING
HER BY. ATTORNEY I BEING BY THE
DECK SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
CHALLENGES JUST EIGHTY THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TAKE AWAY
THE LICENSE OR GIVE THEM
ANCILLARY- RELIEF THEY CAN FIND.
THANK YOU CENTER JUST SAID NO
THE FALL QUESTION AND- BASED ON
YOUR EXAMPLE YOU GAVE ME OF
WITH THE DVL ALSO BE REQUIRED
TO NOTIFY OTHER AGENCIES SUCH
AS THE AG'S OFFICE- ON CASES
JUST EVENT THERE'S NO
DUPLICATION OF SERVICES. OR
DATS- IF THERE'S INSTITUTION
DATA COULD FACE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS THAT THERE'S NOT
MULTIPLE AGENCIES- GETTING
INVOLVED IN THE SAME VIOLATION-
OF FUTURE PLEASE THAT'S NOT
EXPLICITLY PROVIDED FOR NOTICE
IN THIS BILL GENERALLY THE-ATTORNEY GENERAL ASKS IS THE
ATTORNEY FOR ALL THE AGENCIES
SO. IF THEY MOVE BEYOND
REGULATORY- ACTION IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL BE
INVOLVED. THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. ANY MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MCCANN FONG. THANK YOU
A CENTER IF YOU COULD CLARIFY-
FOR MEAT DOES THE NEW LICENSING
AND REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS
DOES DOES THAT JUST APPLY TO
BUSINESSES IN THE BUSINESS OF
DEBT COLLECTION OR DOES IT
APPLY TO BUSINESSES THAT
COLLECTS DATA- LIKE A- WATER
BILL YOU KNOW OTHER OTHER
AGENCIES SO IT'S WE'RE FOCUSING
ON THE ACTIVITY THAT PEOPLE
AREN'T INVOLVED. SO RIGHT NOW
IS THE IS THE BANKERS TESTIFIED
WE EXEMPT BANKS CREDIT UNIONS
THOSE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
ARE ALREADY THERE WE'RE IF YOU
UNDER ROSENTHAL UNDER EXISTING
LAW DEFINES WE PULLED THE
LANGUAGE FROM THE ROSENTHAL ACT
IT'S AS IF YOU CONTINUOUSLY
ENGAGED IN DEBT COLLECTION AND
THAT'S THE ACTIVITY THAT YOU'RE
INVOLVED IN. THEN YOU WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO GET THE LICENSE.
THAT IS SO. FOR EXAMPLE OF IF I
DON'T PAY MY CABLE BILL AND IT
WOULD END THE NIGHT OCCURRED A
DEBT THAT I NEED TO PAY BACK
WOOD. WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
APPLY TO. THOSE COMPANIES THE-
NO NO NOT NOT NOT AN. ONE ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S A LAWYER
WHO HAPPENS HAVE A LAW DEGREE
BUT THEY ENGAGE IN THE DEBT
COLLECTION BUSINESS CONTINUALLY
SO JUST ONE CASE OR ONE OFF ON
A CLIENT THIS IS A- PORTFOLIO
OF DATA. THAT YOU. YOU OBTAIN
FROM SOMEBODY AND YOU'RE IN THE
BUSINESS OF COLLECTING ON THAT
DEBT. OKAY I THINK I GOT IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MEMBERS ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CNN I
WANT TO THANK. THE AUTHOR I FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE- BUT
ALSO FOR YOUR WORK- ON THE
AMENDMENTS YOU MADE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AT THIS BILL DOES
HAVE AN I. RECCO AND- WE
WOULDN'T YEAH DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SUMMER WEBER SECOND.
A SECOND BY SOME MEMBERS STONE
AND CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OR ACTUALLY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- TONIGHT THOUGH THANK
YOU. SB NINE OH EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION.
AMOUNT AYE LIMóN AYE CHAN.
CHEN NO BARRICADE HAND THERE
QUE HAN I BERMAN BERMAN HI
BURKE. FONG. FONG NO OKAY.
GABRIEL GRAYSON GRAYSON HIGH
THREE OF US THREE OF US NIGHT
STONE STONE VOEPEL. VOEPEL NO
WEBER. WEBER AT. THE BILL HAS
EIGHT BOTH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES TO AND
IT DOES PASS TO ON TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AT
THIS TIME I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK THE STAFF ON
THE BANKING COMMITTEE THIS IS
OUR LAST HEARING OF THE YEAR
AND IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH THEM FOR ALMOST THREE
YEARS- AND- THEY'VE DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB IT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE TO BE FAIR AND TO
WORK. WITH A TEAM OF ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF SO MANY ISSUES-
THAT WE FACED IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS BUT MORE STE ESPECIALLY
IN THIS LAST YEAR SO THANK YOU
TO THE TEAM. THERE YOU GO. SO
WITH THAT WE WILL DO I DON'T.
AND SO I WILL DO ADD ONS FOR.
SB. NINE OH EIGHT. SB NINE OH
EIGHT BURKE BURKE ALL RIGHT
PERFECT. SO THE BILL IS
OFFICIALLY OUT NINE ZERO. NINE
VOTES AYE AND THREE AND NO. THE
WITH THAT WE WILL CLOSE THE
AREA.